a club of nine people wants to choose a
board of three officers a president a
vice president and a secretary how many
ways are there to choose the board from
the nine people
now we're going to assume that some for
one person can't hold more than one
office that is that if i'm picked for
president that i'm no longer a valid
person for vice president or secretary
so let's just think about the three
different positions so you have the
president
you have the president
you have the vice president
vp and then you have the secretary
secretary
now let's say that we go for the
president first it actually doesn't
matter let's say we were picking the
president's slot first and we haven't
appointed any of their slots yet how
many possibilities are there for
president well the club has nine people
so there's nine possibilities for
president there's going to be nine
possibilities for president now
we're going to pick one of those nine
we're going to kind of take them out of
the running for the other two offices
right because someone's going to be
president so one of the nine is going to
be present there's nine possibilities
but one of the nine is going to be
president so you take that person aside
he or she is now the president how many
people are left to be vice president
well now there's only eight possible
candidates for vice president eight
possibilities now you he or she also
goes aside now how many people are left
for secretary well now there's only
seven possibilities for secretary so if
you want to think about all of the
different ways there are to choose a
board for out of from the nine people
there's the nine for president times the
eight for vice president
times the seven
times the 7 for secretary you didn't
have to do it this way it could have
been you could have picked secretary
first and there would have been nine
choices and then you could pick vice
president there was still been eight
choices then you could have pricked
president last there would have only
been seven choices but either way you'd
have got 9 times 8 times 7 and that is
let's see 9 times 8
9 times 8 is 72
72 times 7 is 2 times 7 is 14 7 times 7
is 49 plus 1 is 50. so 504
504 possible ways to pick your board out
of a club of only 9 people